[phone ringing]
Hey.
Hey, Marty.
Hey, guys.
NARRATOR: [inaudible]
joins Rick Lagina
and other members of the Oak
Island team in the war room.
So, big brother, how'd
your trip to New York go?
Tell me.
I'll tell you in one word.
I was stunned.
Wow.
NARRATOR: One week ago, Rick
received the shocking news
that his close friend,
researcher and author
Zena Halpern, had passed away.
[knocking on door]
Rick also learned that Zena had
bequeathed to him the results
of her life's work, including
a vast trove of books
and documents, which seem
to connect the Oak Island
mystery to activities involving
the Knights Templar as
far back as the 12th century.
I'm just so thrilled to know
that her life's work isn't
just going to stop right now.
I guarantee you it's not
going to stop, Devin, Jason.
It's not going to stop.
She wouldn't allow it to
stop, and we won't do either.
Thank you, brother.
Yup.
The amount of material
that Zena has wrought,
the width and breadth of
the lady's accomplishments
and research, it was stunning.
That is the word.
Stunning.
Is it tied to Oak Island?
I think we all
have just a very
rudimentary
understanding of the work
as it relates to Oak Island.
The information is
somewhat disjointed.
Do you have the
information with you?
You have it all?
I have some of it, but
there were so much that we
have to have it shipped.
The information will
all come to Oak Island.
So one of the things
that was found
is a actual copy of
the Cremona document.
And it's a deposition by
this English Templar knight.
It's a description of a
year long voyage to the New
World, what's called Onteora.
I know what this is.
This is at the core of
your mother's research.
NARRATOR: While packing up
Zena's collection of research,
Rick discovered a copy of
what is known as the Cremona
document, a collection of
maps and journal passages
reportedly authored by
the 12th century Templar
knight Ralph de Sudeley.
It describes not only
de Sudeley's journey
to the Temple
Mount in Jerusalem,
where he claimed
to have recovered
priceless religious
treasures including
the ark of the covenant,
but also a Templar voyage
to the New World
in the year 1178,
more than three centuries
before Christopher Columbus
made landfall in North America.
I don't know if
this is 100% accurate.
I don't.
Right.
I do believe
with 100% certainty
that it's worth some
commitment of ours
to try to come to
an understanding
of whether not only is this
relevant, but is it accurate?
Here's my thought.
We've now come into possession
of some remarkable research.
A lifetime's worth of research.
Literally.
And to that end, I propose that
we establish a research center.
A place where we can gather the
information regarding our work,
our pursuit of answers for
the Oak Island mystery,
and commit ourselves
to that endeavor.
I want to carry
her work forward.
I do.
Once seen as research
is here and housed here,
it will foster this sense
of that the information
hunt is, indeed, important.
I believe there's a lot more
to glean from her research,
and who knows where
those paths lead us.
I think the future of that
research, Zena's legacy,
if you will, is in very
good hands on Oak Island.
It sounds to me like the
research center idea is timely
because, you know, it's going
to take some real digging
to mess with this.
So keep going, keep digging, is
all I can say, and see what's--
try and separate out
fact from fiction.
I'm going to make certain
that we follow up on this.
- Good job, you guys.
- All right.
See ya.
Talk to you later.
Bye